We have a really crazy situation in the United
States where because of the mishandling of
corona virus by the president.
Americans are trapped in the United States.
Now, this applies to health care.
As many of you probably know.
It's common that Americans will go to Canada
for insulin where it can be obtained much
less expensively.
It's common that Americans along the southern
border will go to Mexico for eye and dental
care.
I've shown these maps before, but if you look,
for example, at the Mexican town, small city
of Los Algodones, you see that it is just
filled with eye and dental clinics.
Why is this?
It's because Americans cross the border to
get high quality, affordable eye and dental
care.
Except that now, because of corona virus,
Americans are allowed almost nowhere around
the world.
We have a health care system that is such
a fiasco that regularly people will escape
the United States for medical treatment while
now they can't.
In addition to just medical treatment, many
people leave the United States for education
to go someplace where college is less expensive.
That's increasingly difficult to do.
Now, with Corona virus, I have friends who
have figured it out, who, for example, they
want to be in Europe to get away from what's
going on.
Europe is not.
Most countries are not allowing Americans
in.
So they go to the U.K. where you can quarantine
for 14 days.
If coming from the U.S., then you're in and
you can travel to other European countries.
But this is really a major issue.
More than two million Americans regularly
buy prescriptions abroad.
That's mostly Canada and Mexico and somehow
are horrible.
Health care system has been made even worse
by restricting the ability of Americans to
essentially flee to other countries with more
affordable health care.
And you still have people who don't recognize
that we need dramatic and drastic systemic
change to the American health care system
now.
If you want to go beyond medical, we've become
the world's pariah.
We were the laughing stock.
We now were the pity of the world.
And people are also angry at the irresponsibility
of what's going on in the United States.
And, you know, I mentioned a few weeks ago.
It has occurred to me to just get out of the
U.S. in the fall for what will likely be a
very difficult public health situation.
And part of the reason that has held me back
from confirming those plans is I am not that
interested in being seen in other parts of
the world as the irresponsible Americans who
are just traveling around and potentially
spreading coronavirus.
Obviously, I would be careful.
I would wear a mask, I would get a test, I
would quarantine, I would do all of that stuff.
But but I don't want to be seen that way.
So Donald Trump's cult has gotten what they
wanted.
They've essentially gotten close borders.
We've closed many of our borders from people
coming in, although that's starting to loosen
because let's be honest, the problem is increasingly
here, not in other countries.
And the United States is now on a blacklist
in most parts of the world.
It's only taken one hundred and eighty seven
thousand dead in order to get those borders
closed so that Americans increasingly can't
leave the United States.
Now, just as a reminder on health care, back
in July, Donald Trump told Chris Wallace during
that interview.
Within two weeks, we'll sign a new health
care plan into law.
Never happened.
Then Trump said it would be done by the end
of August.
Well, that's today.
It's not going to happen every single day.
Trump should be pressed on that because it
is yet another one of those failed, broken
promises, unfortunately.
And this really is horrible for us.
And I know, you know, people write to me from
all over the world who who watch the program
and they feel bad mostly.
The U.S. is feeling more and more like Gilli
ad The World, described by Margaret Atwood
in her two novels, Handmaid's Tale and more
recently, the sequel Testament's.
It's very bad.
It is very, very bad.
Americans trapped in the United States.